j'ai confondu une brune avec un bras ça
c'est jean pascal c'est sûr à perdre on
voudrait tout la liste non pas vous dire
que jean pascal gentil toile et pourquoi
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi ce que j'ai
dit que sa tragédie c'est qu'ils
faisaient
mais je sais pas c'est le feeling que
j'ai je sens que ça peut être lui donc
ça veut pas ça veut dire que cette
personne était un homme était un homme
et que vous pensez que c'était une femme
et que vous avez fait que oui c'est vrai
oui
[Applaudissements]
il faut la ricoh la raconter
en hausse sauf dans les bien évidemment
c'est les vacances je sais mais enfin
quand même
d'accord le soir la température était
douce sinon je fais ça en fait voilà je
suis sortir en discothèque très sympa à
biarritz était une boîte au mot
d'ailleurs une très bonne santé
et j'ai eu une petite gâterie voilà par
une jolie brune et en remontant m'a dit
mais c'était un joli brun
et voilà donc je suis un peu tombé dans
si je vais y penser parce
j'ai toujours été froide connaissez bien
c'est arrivé c'est pas grave c'est un
jeu plus de détails merci beaucoup voilà
on sélectionne anecdotes parce que je
vais revenir
bien très bien de toi j'en passe
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas pris le menu du resto mais
le serveur moi je dis ramasser la sas et
non leur estomac fichman ont menacé vous
tu vois où vous êtes en vacances
tranquillement réseau soutient vous
savez combien j'adore
donc vous êtes à saint martin est un
dirty dozen oui bien sûr que ça c'est
beau c'est juste
pour mon mari qui est un gars bien sûr
on est au restaurant bah oui on va dîner
au restaurant avec des amis on commande
la carte ouais là le garçon à malacca et
le serveur et canonissime lui la bimbo
garçon que j'ai jamais vu de toute ma
vie et donc s'entraînant show maryse à
parme en série est tombée lors alors
dont vous avez la ville a donc donc
comment vous faites pour a pour eux très
je n'ai jamais beaucoup d'arguments à
l'époque j'étais pas comme ça
jamais d'autres atouts quoi et donc je
vois le mec arriver donc ce fameux chez
m et je le regarde sa peur il s'appelait
chiriaev un sioux
est
ce qu'on peut oui et donc bah voilà
comment je vais emballé je regarde le
menu et où je regarde et je lui ai dit
tout simplement que ce que je voulais
c'était pas la carte qu'on t'a dit ça
bah ouais ouais d'accord est donc très
jeune et fougueux ouais mais harcha moi
ça va j'ai regardé bayer mais non plus
aller ou pas direct voilà bah c'est ce
qu'il a fait en direct alors un autre
temps notre tendresse
gp chaumont trouve d'aquagym en turquie
mais alors alors d un régime ça ça ça
enlève sans
gilbert d'ailleurs ça peut être ou
magali gilles non
celui-ci fait des vacances apuanes donc
bah oui oui et alors naissant de la
cogema roll
non je n'en sais c'est où vous ou magali
house et maggie may est normal et c'est
delphine belle china oui c'est moi
l'atce pas tout à fait exact en fait
j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour mon prof
de d'aquagym c'est vrai j'avais 14 ans
lui donnerait peut-être 22 et c'est vrai
il est très très beau et ça et pendant
tout le mal que vous avez qui attendons
plutôt saison non
18 18
et donc est donc maintenant
donc vous n'avez 18 ans et j'avais 18
ans à l'hôpital cinq
[Applaudissements]
et on n'arrêtait pas de se regarder et
tout est vraiment été magnifique et le
dernier jour il voulait venir vers moi
pour me pour me dire au revoir il
voulait m'embrasser r il m'a collé
contre le mur et voulait m'embrasser et
moi je sais tellement timide et j'ai
tourné la joue et en fait il m'a juste
un bisou sur la joue et je m'en veux
encore aujourd'hui c'est ça un beau
tracé pour elle je n'ai pas pension
c'est tout mais non super je suis père
tué à droite moi ça veut rien dire on
peut être droite et l'isu et moi-même
suis très droit s'appelait sony et et
non j'ai rien fait pour samy ceni comme
le zonage trop
chaud ni cheyenne on est dans les tous à
l'été s'est dit allez on va avancer en
voulant monter ma jante je me suis dit
avec un thé en voulant monter ma tante
may s'est fait démonter
comme amiens jeu alors ça c'est gilbert
bernard non alors c'est où bernard ou
gilles verdez et renard non non non
c'est vous ouais c'est moi
ces salons on est dans un contexte qu'au
moment des dons dans un club novation de
liste alors non là c'était l'époque
camping sauvage ab cèze dans le gard ben
oui bien sûr j'ai déjà raconté je
faisais les élections mister camping
sauvage qui mal un certain succès
chaque année
on était trois candidates et médaille
d'argent
et donc en fait donc on s'installait
dans un prêt et on
nintendo tente et on avait un
emplacement chaque année revenait au
même endroit quand je voyais des jeunes
qui arrivait dans le gard ya beaucoup
d'étrangers arrivé je les conduisaient
là et pour commencer à m'intéresser à
elle je montais leurs tentes alors dire
vous avez un emplacement gratuit et tout
ça est donc cette année là il y avait
des jeunes néerlandais ce qui était
arrivé à hull pas qu'elles font très
très sympathique
il venait et danger la rocade
est donc l'intérêt on va à l'eau
commence à flirter cetera aloe parole à
l'eau mais ce que j'avais oublié ce que
je ne savais pas c'est que son père
était dans le vrai qu'hormis lui à habas
et donc il nous a chopé dans l'eau comme
suis très à l'aise dans l'eau je
tournais autour d'elle et de cette voie
là bas c'est le dauphin du
ballet aquatique il nous a choisis il
nous a suivis il m'a engueulé il m'a
presque démonter comme ça ils avaient
forcé il a laissé sa fille il m'a fait
démonter ma tante moi j'étais avec des
potes donc j'ai perdu la néerlandaise a
chez ma tante et j'ai perdu mes potes
qui m'ont dit on en a ras-le-bol de toi
casse toi ah ben voilà on se cache c'est
[Applaudissements]
comme ça alors j'ai eu la gastro pendant
une année sur un bateau de plongée alors
ça c'est alors ça c'est dit nicolas
schatz et 500 lanaken stuff
donc marchés plongent dj stoxx la
médaille mes parents j'avais craqué sur
une charmante jeune fille que je suis
arrivé à embarquer avec moi en bateau
pourrait faire de la plongée on a passé
deux heures comme ça de loulle mais
quand je suis arrivé au bout au moment
d'aller faire la plonge et je me suis
bien vomir j'avais une garce qui a passé
deux heures d'horreurs sur le bateau et
j'avais honte pour la dégaine à castres
on vomit passe à 6 en
deux heures et quand on est arrivé là
bas c'est il ya tout dégueulasse que
jamais que vous savez qu'on peut moi
j'ai parmi les anges est ébranlée de
plongée première dans le détendeur s m
est arrivé à gênés avec avec mais avec
on appelle ça une palanquée donc j'avais
des des élèves il y en a qui jouent prix
très très mal et tout d'un coup de frais
distribuer sans te veux et c'est une
jackie
il faut pas pas une équipe à ce que
il faut pas paniquer parce que on rit
c'est bien beau de se noyer les fossiles
est malade en reconnaissant dans les
prochaines heures si vous écoutez oui
c'est vrai
ils ont bon appétit doré découvrir ces
parcelles la wii
est donc lavé libertin j'ai fait l'amour
dans une cabine de plage bon sens
absolument pas c'est pas moi c'est mon
voisin non c'est moi c'est vous alors je
vais vous dire c'est à l'époque ma vie
c'est vrai qu'elle est l'icône interview
vous dire non il ya vraiment 40 ans
était arc à sion il avait installé des
cabines de plage alors non rigoler et
vous savez comme toutes les promenades
de plage il ya tous les restaurants les
bars et salles étaient très en forme etc
je ramène quelqu'un évidemment dans une
cabine savoises étaient toutes fermées
mais stocker l'avim qui était
entrouverte donc évidemment on était
pieds nus dans le sable tous un peu
bourré et c'est avec modération
évidemment il se trouve que quand on est
rentré là dedans c'était mou et puis
d'un coup il ya une odeur et qui a été
démis c'est alors
qu'est ce qui fait que nous le sommes
toujours très très dur sa copine je vous
explique non ah bon je sais bien que
bâchée oui et je marchais est en fait
cette cabine j'ai compris pourquoi il
était un peu entrouverte avec toi
lesquels servi de chez eux
les deux partout
mais quasiment plongé et donc fait des
libertés vous êtes tombée amoureuse d'un
nudisme est alors davantage quand on est
encore le lycée compte au moins on sait
où va alors oui mais justement je savais
pas je sortais j'ai grandi à saint
tropez et j'étais dans une boîte de nuit
voilà j'avais 17 ans et là je rencontre
un gars magnifique j'y suis la
magnifique donc le drague et s'appelait
cheyenne il dit
[Rires]
j'appelais de mes copines moi on se voit
demain je vais demain donc rendez-vous
dans son camping j'arrive au camping -
quand nous de nous disent je l'appelle
jetez y un problème je suis dans un
camping de nudistes sait où madiba c'est
là et là je vois le mec sortir avec le
bouc
et le zizi à l'air et l'âge h mais
qu'est-ce que ça je rentre je suis la
seule 9 à billets quand même c'était
horrible c'était aydin chénens pas
possible et là bas le mec me dit j'ai
froid il met son pull mais il oublie de
cacher sa quête futée c'est non merci
c'est comme manager très
négatif bagis et il est trop ma nature
respect qu'il existe en chacun sait du
bistouri mais contre moi c'est gênant
mais la taille qui lui a pas plu et et
vous vous donnez un spécialiste de
nudisme bah oui
parce que c'est la différence d'ailleurs
j'en sais rien
alors et c'est arrivé il est haut gradé
paraît-il gradé dans le monde du
week-end dans les alpes de haute
provence je peux vous dire que vous
parlez moi tout le monde afflue ah bah
oui
les colonels
dans le match des étoiles
nous faisions il à san diego la
écoutez vous allez partir dans l'inconnu
dit cela crée tout mais on en fait au
nom non ça c'était avec mes parents au
passé une dizaine d'années tifenn g
t'imagines pacte et avec tes vieux
l'elite
balader rosserie wissous le monde était
nu ces sites à migrer ou tout ça mais on
est des très bons naturistes dans la
famille ben oui bah oui ils sont tous
comme la famille non non non non
on a initié quelques cousins quand même
regarder la licencier vous avez un
nourrisson vous étiez un gros dragueur
ou pas oui oui oui
en fait j'étais souvent draguer
réussite sportive la notoriété c'était
c'était plus dans le sens là alors
est-ce qu'ils aient eu un en profitait
forfait dit puisque a eu un avant et un
après médaille de bronze aux jo 94 par
exemple alors j'étais déjà avec ma femme
aird alors 94 mais il ya eu un avant et
94 a bien vécu c'est à dire savoir que
tout ça va on a vécu je pense que j'ai
pas beaucoup de fantasmes que j'ai pas
réalisé très bien alors on va y aller
doucement quand même a fait part si en
fait j'ai pu vraiment de toi comme en
gros ils ont la découvrir ah oui ah oui
exemple cette fois
alors oui moi j'aime à naples le truc
alors j'ai on va tout savoir j'aimerais
savoir toujours des filles est prêt et
ce plaisir à beaucoup de bonnes n'est
jamais trop plein jour et dans la
gestion me disait un ami homosexuel qui
me disait tu sais faut pas mourir haut
niveau vient de mourir et dur oui oui
oui il faut le double à gages mais je me
suis je vais attendre un petit peu de
temps que
j'ai créé 50 ans et ça ne vous avez
essayé avec des patineuses après des
compétitions même pendant la compétition
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
surtout pas trop loin non restons
proches est ce qu'on pourra jouer
parfois il fallait y aller un peu oui
mais sinon non sur moi j'ai fait sur la
patinoire même nom
du patineur ou nageurs gym à une fan de
patin avec les patins aux pieds non
quand même pas parce que c'est plus
facile que ma femme le soir aux juifs la
bague de fiançailles est beau quand même
prenant pas assez bossé mitraillette
et donc au point avec le directeur de la
patinoire pour que ça se passe il a
évidemment
pas de téléphone portable pour quelqu'un
pour nous filmer et bien là dès le cul
dans la glace je veux sûr que ce roman
vous et merci thierry